[Music]
there will be no jokes this morning
about heavy ions given this given the
speaker the league Rajan's suckered me I
excuse me
persuaded me to give this talk a couple
of weeks ago or maybe a month back asked
me to spend a little bit of time talking
about life with the heavy iron group as
I'm going to rechristen it it was
actually there when I was here it was
the maybe still known as the Van de
Graaff group even though the event the
last real Van de Graaff at MIT had been
shut down if about a year and a half
before I came here and sometime in very
early 70s so the time I came here the
group had already turned into a users
group but even so we managed to continue
running at Van de Graaff so we just had
to go across Long Island Sound to get to
them so most of what I'm going to talk
about in terms of what I was doing when
I was here was actually done in user
mode down at Brookhaven National
Laboratory I was here from 73 to 78 I
came from University of Tennessee partly
on two sets of recommendations one was a
fella who is a year ahead of me at UT
named Tom to grant some of you and the
theory department may remember Tom he
was a Knoxville native and I was from a
smaller town in East Tennessee we got to
know each other and senior mechanics
class it was only offered every other
year so he had come back to take it with
us juniors the other thing that
persuaded me to come here was a series
of letters I had some time in early 73
once that came from Dave Frisch who was
here in charge of getting graduate
students in that year the other was from
Willie Fowler who was of course Cal Tech
who would was trying to persuade me to
go out there and study nuclear
astrophysics with him I was somewhat
torn between the two decisions I didn't
get very strong advice one way the other
until David finally wrote me the third
letter and said that he beat the Johnny
Reb out of me and make me a Yankee yet
if I just come up here and give him a
chance so given that challenge I of
course had to take him up on it and came
on up that fall when I got here the
group over in building 58 which is where
I was parked for a few years was in the
process of putting together
variant on an Angus split-pole this is
being done down at Brookhaven the
variation was that instead of the usual
two pole magnet arrangement which harold
and invented some few years prior we had
added a Veen filter in front of it the
idea being to be able to in addition to
momentum focusing you could also do em
over cue focusing that was important for
doing heavy ion physics where you had to
deal with a range of charge states and
masses all at the same time
Bill Buckner was still around then and
when he I came in and took my obligatory
introduction to the laboratory bill
asked me what I'd like to work on since
in his opinion all good graduate
students had to get their hands dirty
preferably as quickly as possible he
managed to pry out of me that I'd been
cement the previous summer working at
Eastman Kodak in one of the chemistry
groups summer employment between
undergraduate and graduate school and
one thing in particular I had done is
running NMR spectrometer all summer so
we said oh that's wonderful
we'll put you to work we have a NMR
which we need to get running for this
new spectrograph down at Brookhaven here
it is I expect you know please rebuild
it get the oscillator to work and the
driver and make us a few new probes and
a few other little details so I took
this job on not really knowing any
better it looked a little old
fortunately I was at the time had been
hooked up as a teaching assistant to
supplement my fellowship I was under the
supervision I think of Rayner vice at
the time and he'd sent me over to help
out with the junior lab which meant I
had access to a nice small compact
electromagnet with a good feel quality
so I could check this NMR and I
proceeded to rebuild it it was a little
worrisome because I opened it and it was
all full of these things called vacuum
tubes which proved to be problematic
because none of the stores had vacuum
tubes anymore you could buy and several
of them didn't work anymore this problem
we solved somehow by going and talking
to somebody back in the depths of the
physics stockroom who certainly had a
few of the necessary vintage tubes
the thing that disconcerted me though is
when Harold finally gave me the prints
for the oscillator and I realized that
the prints had been drawn the year I was
born so this thing was not exactly the
newest piece of equipment ever but bill
told me later he thought that you should
work on things of
your own vintage and he certainly meant
it after that I after working with the
group I spent the next summer at
Brookhaven under Harold's suggestion we
had an engineer from Denmark who come
over name of Hudson who needed some
young fellow who didn't know any better
to help him put the spectrograph
together I was of course put to work
drilling holes and wiring and power
supplies and all the other good things
experimentalist learn how to do hair all
came down that fall and we tuned the
whole thing up and here I'll finally
decide that the acronym for the thing
should be the energy mass spectrograph
for EMS as I've marked on the slide
Harold's rationale for wanting to call
it the EMS was that when it didn't work
we could just invert the two first
letters of the spec of the name to call
it the mass energy spectrograph or miss
for short which summarized maybe the
first year of shift but then it worked
rather well and we had a good time with
it I'm gonna at this point talk a little
bit about some of the physics I've got
three things I've picked out from what I
did here I've listed the cast of
characters that were over and we were
partly spread between building 58 and
partly in building 26 on the fourth and
fifth floors I spent a good bit of time
when I came working with Eric Cosman and
Hera Langa and Steve Steadman I was here
when I came here still as a senior
scientist and later became my thesis
adviser about 75 when I finally decided
I should pick a topic and think about
getting out I worked with Lee also some
on one topic I'll come to at the end
I've listed here all the graduate
students and postdocs who I can remember
working with and whose names I could
flush out from the papers they're about
20 people they're 12 of whom went on for
PhD a few were postdocs and there's some
number of undergraduates we always seem
to have a Manute to the pushing from
Eric we always had a fairly steady
supply of your op students working with
us and I was lucky to be able to help a
few of them through their senior thesis
which was good training for a graduate
student when I came in the door here the
topic that Carl van Bieber put me to
work on as far as data reduction was
looking at a series of resonances that
had been found of the previous year
before I came
looking at carbon/carbon reactions what
Eric had become interested in studying
was what happens if he took two heavy
ions and put them together and asked the
question if you excited any states of
any particular special structure up in
the compound nucleus this was a subject
of some speculation there had been a
series of measurements made about a
decade earlier by Bromley at all looking
at residences near the Coulomb barrier
and Eric and Karl had managed to find
through one of the last ever exposures
using the MIT multi gap this was done at
Brookhaven but if you shot carbon and
carbon together it varied the bombarding
energy from about 32 to 44 MeV in the
lab this is shown down here at the
bottom in terms of center of mass energy
then lo and behold if you looked at the
proton exit channel which would give you
states in sodium 23 you found
particularly in one region a number of
states especially these two at 9:07 and
984 and also a pair up around 12 and 14
all of which seemed to follow one
another as you vary the bombarding
energy which was suggestive of resonance
structure or as we like to call them in
the group molecular states so we spent
quite a bit of time he should this phys
right this particular paper was
published in 74 and after I'd been here
about a year we had a another one where
we had continued this process this is
the first paper I think I was involved
with in the group and we worked with two
fel that we'd gone out to Argonne over
that winter worked with John Erskine Lee
Greenwood Oscar Hansen was visiting at
Brookhaven at the time we had teamed up
with him and by that point we'd managed
to systematize things enough to where we
had a fairly good idea of the whole
landscape there was a this one enormous
figure which Eric kept up on the
bulletin board over in building 58 which
we would add to sort of honor every few
weeks basis as we managed to get a few
more states analyzed what we've done is
plot again as a function in this case
we've systematized it all as a function
of excitation energy in magnesium 24
running up here along the top and we've
looked at a fairly large number of
states and particularly Eric it had us
look at the members
the ground-state rotational ban in
sodium 23 when the ground states of cape
i three-halves plus state these four
states we looked at these two here were
the ones that have been most prominent
earlier and after a certain amount of
analysis we'd realize that we evidently
had fairly good correlated structure at
these three energies here and maybe
something starting to happen out here at
the tail end though we've gotten rather
hard to see in these states we also were
able to measure the deuteron channels
and find measurements in the literature
of the inverse reaction of alpha on neon
all of which seemed to go together this
finally led us to argue that perhaps you
saw some evidence for systematic
structure in this which Eric suggested
could be interpreted as a highly
deformed rotational band in fact we
finally referred to it as a resonance
rotational band what I'm showing here is
a plot quite favored in high spin gamma
physics where you plot the square of the
angular momentum versus excitation
energy the ground state band in
magnesium 24 sits here there's a clutter
of low lying states that are well-known
the threshold for carbon carbon starts
here what you find that these states
whose spin was slowly worked out in
later years by other people so our
guesses here were based on likelihoods
of branching ratios and knowing what
states were being populated and photon
decays all of which we'd measured and
you had the indication that perhaps you
had a band here that was a series of
states all collected and correspond to
some rather deformed states in the
carbon we went on and studied this for a
number of years further I think Tom
Cormier took his thesis on this data now
Lazzarini took his face in his thesis
out of this set of data partly that show
here where we've gone through and looked
at a few other channels and found that
we can match resonances an excitation
functions with states with that are
preferentially populated in alpha decay
from silicon-28 and I think Bob would do
went through and finally completed the
elastic scattering measurements and a
few other and the did a reanalysis of
the reaction is shown here the carbon
carbon going to alpha neon for his
thesis just as I recall this this one
last piece of this work was probably
mr. round 82 or 83 as I recall a number
of years after I'd left simultaneous
with that even though I worked quite a
bit on that Tom Cormier had managed to
build a time of flight spectrometer
which we had installed at Brookhaven and
Tom had we'd started using it to measure
heavy on transfer reactions got a few
papers but all in all had not learned
anything particularly unusual from those
reactions other than aspects of how to
properly do D WBA when you have heavy
ions whose recoils have to be dealt with
properly which wasn't always done good
old days of DP stripping what we had
found once we as we were getting this
thing running the rumors and papers
started coming from our colleagues in
France and also on some certain West
Coast labs somewhere out near San
Francisco that if you looked at heavy
ions and didn't restrict yourself just
to the transfer region or the compound
nucleus region but took a broad brush
there was a much broader structure that
you might see and this was discussed at
some detail yesterday by professors
Fishbach and Coonan
it's became become known as deeper
deeply inelastic scattering by that
point what one finds is that there's a
considerable amount of nucleon and
energy exchange without a fusion
reaction or even a fission reaction
going on just to set a landscape what
I've done here is pull a plot from a
paper that was sort of the beginnings of
Carl Van boobers and my thesis this was
what we plot here is a massive reaction
product actually this is not a
linearized plot so it's the lines aren't
terribly straight but this coordinate is
roughly masked and this coordinate is
linearly proportional to energy of what
comes out which is the first sort of the
easy information from time-of-flight
spectrometer the normal landscape on
such a plot would have looked like this
you'd see a clutter of protons and
alphas down here in the lower left
corner the Norn er normal evaporation
products a group of compound nuclei
which for an asymmetric system were
going to be lumbering along at a fairly
low energy and then all the transfer and
elastic products around where the beam
sat and what you saw instead was this
rather broad sweep in particular this
distribution of strength right around
the projectile mass if you looked in
detail at this group over here you found
that in fact you could understand most
of that is compound nucleus decay you're
simply of such an energy that there's a
lot of mass emission but if you then
came down and looked at the angular
distributions in various windows of
q-value it's too broad to pick out a
particular States you could you would
then find that the angular distributions
didn't really match anything you knew
very well it turns out that if you
recall these contour plots you saw
yesterday what I'm showing you here are
simply some slices through these at
constant final state kinetic energy or Q
value window was we chose to call it in
this paper what I've done is look at
mass 17 groups and mass 12 groups and
show you as the things get more and more
inelastic this is nearly elastic
reactions and these are highly inelastic
reactions pushing up near the the
kinematic limit for the reaction you
find things simply get more and more
relaxed becoming fission like but never
quite making it became a bit of a
industry then to study exactly what was
going on this particular paper got as
far as noticing that if you looked at
how the most likely in elasticity which
is shown on the ordinate here varied as
a function of mass transfer
we're not moving any mass at all
corresponds to the middle you see a
trend which suggests you perhaps that
what you're looking at is successive
nucleon exchange which is these
exchanges proceed you tend to get more
and more in elasticity you finally tend
to run up against a kinematic boundary
which is a bit mushy this is the
boundary you'd expect for two touching
charge spheres that hadn't deformed we
went on and studied this for a number of
years Carl and I did theses looking at
the the polarization of the products
which were emitted Steve Coonans view
video yesterday showed you some evidence
for how these things spin as they pull
apart
well got interested in the polarization
I got interested in how much I angular
momentum and therefore gamma nerves were
emitted other people got interested in
exactly how the fission branch of this
would worked and how polarized those
fragments were how hard you could push
did the neutrons come before the fission
or after the fission this occupied me
for a number of years after I left here
in fact until roughly the mid 80s at
which point I changed gears rather
thoroughly I wanted to talk about one
last thing we did here it was the reason
I'm going to bring this up is this was
the first project that I did after I
finished my thesis Steve Steadman had
allowed me a certain enough rope to hang
myself my last few months here I stayed
on one year after I took more orals and
as a postdoc we just as I finished in
that summer of 77 that came a paper out
from our colleagues at NBI some of whom
I had worked with particularly
Fault pool Hoffer I'd worked with at
Brookhaven they had decided to go off
and see if there were any more
interesting structures in high spin
physics around the mass 150-160 regime
region where the nuclei are known to be
deformed if they're near the stability
line what they wanted to know is could
you get well off of stability and find
any evidence for isomerism with the
erased line the line that tells you
where the lowest excitation state is a
function of angular momentum sits
would that line stay nice and smooth as
we knew from even knew the nuclei or
where to get jagged enough that you in
fact would develop what we're in
anticipation christened erased traps
States which would say find themselves
unable to decay by an e2 transition
because the nearest e to state below it
was in fact above it next to tation
would the erased line get that jagged so
the hypothesis was that these would form
isomers and what the group had nan bi
and GSI had done is simply take a survey
of worth such isomers like look this is
something you could really do until the
mid 70s because you needed an
accelerator which would put heavy ions
out in a controlled manner at energies
right around the Coulomb barrier you
didn't need the bevel Act which would
tear things apart
he wanted the unil a core a big tendon
which would do things in a controlled
way what they found I should point out
the apparatus a little bit is it's
actually it's devilishly simple you
simply bring a beam on beam in on a
target you bury the target in this case
and a bunch of lead
you then go some distance downstream
allow recoils to come down to a catcher
and then surround that with a number and
a number of sodium iodide detectors so
you're deliberately blind to the prompt
radiation within shielding fraction but
you're able to see any any particles
which decay with isomeric lifetimes on
the order of one to several hundred
nanoseconds which is roughly the recoil
time of these ions to get from here to
here what they found in fact was that
you didn't you found a an entire island
of these things what they show here is a
usual nuclear physics plot of z running
up this way nucleon number running out
this way what they've marked in black or
compound nuclei that were formed they
didn't know what the system was they
just knew that that reaction would lead
to isomerism what's drawn in here in
blue is the line of beta stability
what's drawn in green is a rough
estimate of sort of where the well not
more better-known deform nuclei sit the
rotational limit as it was called in
that paper you define that by asking for
a 4 + 2 2 + transition ratio of about 3
we after reading this we went off and
looking and it turns out I spent a good
part of the next few years studying
those three red dots which are
dysprosium 151 and then two isotopes and
erbium I hooked on reading this paper
week one morning we called Doug Klein at
Rochester the next afternoon and asked
him if we could come up and use his
tandem Peter Butler was at Oak Ridge MIT
at the time as a postdoc and he knew
something about high spin physics so we
went to Rochester set up in experiments
worked very hard to get it set up which
I've drawn a bit of a sketch here in the
corner as to what it looked like it's
the same kind of arrangement though
since we had a tandem we had to we had
to get our time 0 by stuck in sticking
sodium iodide around the target then we
put up some shielding and then germanium
detectors because we wanted to do
spectroscopy there's a bit of a story
about this tungsten shield here I went
off to the I was at Brookhaven I went
over the HDS asking to borrow some
tungsten blocks and they gave me some
after smearing the surface radioactivity
I happily took them away then
fortunately set up a little test over at
the tandem with one of the germanium
detectors to see if they really did
shield properly tried to adjust the
shielding and found out that these were
perfect anti shields I then went back
over to the HS asked exactly which
tungsten box they given me they got a
somewhat unhappy look on their face as
they check the records and realize that
they hadn't handed me the shielding
blocks they'd of course given me a beam
stop this is a terrible story to tell
him the president days of ES and H the
unfortunate aspect of this was that the
fellow realized that the beam stock was
stored in a box which they were using as
a poker table so they there were bad
jokes for a few weeks about real hot
poker games over at the AG SDS NH office
about a week later I noticed that same
box well buried in the shield wall near
professor teens experiments anyhow we
went off and I won't try to go through
this level scheme it was my first and
elastic effort in constructing a level
scheme I decided that I'd chosen wisely
by not becoming a high spin physicist
Kim Lister had most of the fun doing
this in fact but the interesting thing
we found from that is when you study the
shape of the ear S band you in fact get
it rather if you make one of these plots
as I showed you earlier for carbon
carbon in this case this pros in 151 is
the one we mentioned we had measured
what you usually find for a even-even
nucleus closer to stability is a nice
smooth curve and you see instead you get
this very jagged dependence of where the
state's sit as a function of square of
angular momentum and if you in fact just
draw a straight line through that you
get moments of inertia which you're
uncomfortably large there's a conference
fairly soon that they're after when this
was all discussed and the only thing I
can remember from that conference was
Abe Klein continually asking been models
and what a rotating box of nucleons
meant and quantum mechanics have been it
ever did answer the question anyway we
continued these studies after I got the
Oakridge I had Kim had by that point
gone to Brookhaven and dog horn who was
ahead of me at MIT had also gone to
Brookhaven Syrus back to a she come from
Pittsburgh
they asked me down for a summer we did
some more of this and had a good
just to show you what the type thing we
ended up studying and how different
these schemes are we decided to erbium
152 and 153 which are like the
dysprosium case and just add a pair of
protons if you look at the even-even
case you get the usual rather beautiful
arash sequence though those of you who
know this game would notice that you're
so far off stability that what you might
call a backbend is it a suspiciously low
spin value of six to eight instead of
the usual twelve to fourteen however if
you stick that one last Neutron in has
every good nuclear physicist knows this
lovely level scheme turns into this not
so lovely level scheme but to our eyes
this was a thing of beauty because this
showed isomers and that's what we wanted
to study so we had a good time doing
that if you you can in fact we went
through in the paper I think that we
proved that we must getting to be
getting near the end of the experimental
program because in that paper we started
making theoretical conjectures which is
bad for a gang or for experimental
postdocs to be doing but we did it
anyway we couldn't resist taking the
level schemes from dysprosium 150 which
had been worked out in the interim and
the erbium we just measured knows that
these two even-even schemes are fairly
similar the difference being simply this
pair of protons you then in both cases
tack on a neutron and then the
dysprosium 151 you end up with this
sequence of states and spin parity
values and the trained eye can quickly
spot the distraction rather similar as
to what happens over here in the erbium
153 the difference was we didn't run
quite as long and managed to chase out
the f7 have h 9 has band there in the
middle but we we thought that was rather
cute in terms of how things worked out
that the structure didn't change so much
there's one last thing and digging back
to the literature I reread that paper
and in the discussion under experimental
technique there was a little phrase
which I've pulled out here that mentions
this is from the erbium 152 paper we'd
run samarium carbon reactions good
standard compound nucleus reaction where
you let a few nucleon neutrons boil out
and make your compound nuclei and we
comment here that reactions with the
backing material made ray radium 216
lines which the
troublesome contaminants in this
experiment well usually the things like
that stop there but of course dog and
him never let a data tape go unused so a
year later a paper came out about radium
216 lines they decided the tandem had to
go down for repairs that year and so
they were industrious fellows and
analyzed the background almost Thomas
lawn Ruth came over from Finland to to
help us finish that effort now before I
say a few words about Rick since Lee got
me into this I have to say how Lee got
me into Berkeley as and how I met Peter
Butler in Li yang Lee Lee had the idea
late in our my stay here that we ought
to get into the then very current timely
effort to find super heavies and we
spent a little bit of time thinking up
how to do it Lee suggested that we ought
to get off and do something rather
different from what had been done by
other groups they were simply trying to
make things by compound nucleus extend
reactions which is rather difficult up
at high mass because it's difficult to
make the nucleus cold enough that it
won't sit and just boil neutrons off
find itself where it's unstable against
doggone near everything fission decay
alpha rapid alpha decay and and the like
his suggestion was to turn this
instability to fission decay into a
virtue and so what we decided to do was
instead of trying to make things by
compound nuclear routes instead we'd try
to make them by forming a heavy nucleus
which decayed by fission Lee's
suggestion was that we take these beams
of about eight and some-odd MeV per
nucleon actually this is around five of
Krypton which were available now at the
super high Lackey at Berkeley use those
to bombard lead targets and then
the target over at about eighty degrees
so that she'd be nice and thick for
stopping the heavy fragments you can
stop them in about two Pico seconds but
she'd be rather open for looking at the
fission fragments which would come
lumbering out so we put this rather
simple looking set up into the line at
the high lack and I think took a few
shots out there of course everybody
knows what the answer to the experiment
is because fame and fortune were not
ours we ended up with same result as
everybody else would I show you
here is the operative figure from the
paper where we plot the correlated
energies from the two telescopes one on
this axis and then the three recoil
telescope seats in their own box and had
there been large numbers of counts in
these little windows which I show you
here then Peter would have been happy
and Lee would have been famous and so on
but as it was we joined the long list of
people who were able to set limits in
our case we were able to however set
them in an interesting piece of face
space no one had ever looked at things
that were isomeric out to several
hundred nanoseconds the really nice
thing about this technique is that you
can observe until you're tired and turn
the electronics off so if you found
things that were metastable you would in
fact see them in this but we didn't and
I think we set cross-section limits
somewhere in the micro barn range as I
recall well that's sort of what occupied
me up told roughly 1985 was this and
similar studies which went on at Oak
Ridge with the Hollifield machine they
were set up there some of them were done
in collaboration with with Cormier and
Horne who I worked with here and other
people who I then met I spent a few more
years studying isomers of the yang Li
since he also ended up coming to Oak
Ridge in fact is still there now evolved
in the gamma sphere program however
somewhere in the mid 80s I think was 82
or 83 I went to a talk at one of the
early nucleus nucleus conferences I
think it was given by McCloskey lassie
where he described what had come out of
the Bielefeld conference of that summer
and also some observations concerning
what had been seen in recent cosmic ray
events looking at heavy nuclei such as
calcium and iron striking emulsion
targets and what what had been seen
looked rather exciting and this all led
to us going and reading the literature
that winner Bjork ins paper about
suggestions of how one might look for a
D confined state how it might be seen in
a hydro dynamic scaling picture came out
and I decided at that point to shift
gears in a fairly major way specifically
I decided we decided to join the
relativistic heavy ion or what's now but
somehow become known the ultra
relativistic heavy ion game it'll have
to become relativistic I guess once the
SSC going gets going and start looking
at very high-energy collisions and see
if you could see evidence for some
thing quite different go on in nuclei in
this case use them as a hope for tool
for finding finding evidence for quark D
confinement how to describe that in a
few minutes I've got left is a bit of a
challenge I finally decided it would be
best in a talk like this to deal with it
a bit at the cartoon level so I had a
few cartoons I've brought what's meant
by the following graph is just a
discussion of how you might find a
difference between what does discuss
what goes on when you're looking at
instead of a morphic say a familiar
diamagnet of the type that we all know
rather well from superconductivity you
have a situation where you've formed a
condensate of electron pairs and you end
up with in a rather perfect diamagnet
you end up you exclude say a magnetic
field from the centre of a super contact
conductor there when you get down to
what you might loosely refer to as a
nice QED vacuum the opposite possibly
happens in QCD it's as I mentioned time
to gran had something to do with getting
me to come here and part of what he was
doing while he was here was working on
the bag model and occasionally would
tell me stories about how that was going
and how one tried to understand this
rather odd fact that quarks seem to be
real objects that's how you would
understand certain results that we're
seeing it's lack in Brookhaven but they
didn't seem to show up you had to
understand why the why they should stay
confined he might choose to look at that
as the few argue the QCD vacuum is also
a condensate this case of gluon pairs
and QQ bar pairs and you end up with the
inverse case of what you see in a
superconductor instead of the small
region forcing that feels out you get
the vacuum confining the color electric
fields down to the core of a had drawn
what you would then so you would then
end up with a QCD vacuum which you
should describe an electrical language
there's a color elect dielectric what I
have down here at the bottom is then a
sort of a very crude correspondence
chart between the two and where what
you're describing and say in the
superconductivity is you're excluding a
magnetic field on the inside and whereas
what goes on of course in
QCD is you exclude the color electric
field from the outside you can find it
down to the volume of a had rod but you
could then ask what does it take to get
yourself into a situation where that
wasn't just confined to a Hadron but
rather was able to spread out over a
somewhat larger volume of space maybe
one you can even hope to the experiment
with a bit it's been conjectured that
you in fact ought to do that it ought to
be able to be seen if you were able to
compress nuclear matter or heat it up by
some factor which if you expressed it in
density terms might correspond to about
a factor of four you can come up with a
cartoon and it's nothing but that of how
that such a phase diagram might look if
you'll allow yourself to speak and
discuss thermodynamics and strongly
interacting matter in the same sentence
and you might express that as a
something which runs up along a what an
axis which is labeled here is
temperature you can understand that by
asking yourself crudely where that scale
comes from just by asking yourself
what's the energy density inside of a
proton which is of the order of half a
gif per cubic Fermi and what's the
energy density inside of an atomic
nucleus like a LED nucleus the answer in
that case this point one five Geoffrey
cubit Fermi so you could argue to
yourself that if you could crowd the LED
to where everything was overlapping and
there was increased that energy density
by about a factor of three per unit for
a cubic prefer me cubed you come you
come up with a rough estimate of the
order of 300 MeV of course you can make
a much more sophisticated estimate of
where that should sit similarly you can
get a rough guess of where this break
between normal matter we we know and
love and this conjectured plasma
quark-gluon plasma has become known you
could estimate where that sits on the
density scale by taking a bit of a look
at just what the relative volume sizes
are radius parameter a nucleus is one
point two it's 0.8 for a proton if you
take the ratio of those cubed along the
whole yer come up with about four this
of course has had much more
sophisticated investigation than that
here I've picked something from the one
of the papers by the Columbia group
Norman Chris group who
have done fairly large-scale latus case
studies of QCD over the last number of
years and in fact as Professor Coonan
discussed yesterday have built a rather
large and specialized machine to do this
what's shown here is how the entropy in
such a field theory runs as a function
of beta which is proportional to
temperature in that theory and you see a
rather sharp run up of that at a
specific point whether or not this will
actually turn out to be well nice first
order phase transition from what we know
is nuclei to what we call a plasma or
whether it'll be more like the phase
transition of no not no particular order
which is what we know for atomic plasmas
is of course remains to be seen from the
standpoint of what an experimentalist
might think about if you could do this
we hope by colliding to very heavy ions
at high energies if you sort of start
here and here after they pass through
each other these nuclei are pancakes
simply because of Lorentz contraction
you might happen might hope if you do
this at high enough energies such as
that the energies that the Machine
prefer being under constructed at
Brookhaven will do that you might find
yourself in a situation such that the
baryons the network content will be
boosted out of the central region of
face space and you'll be left with the
region covering a number of units of
rapidity which is best described as
purely blue on ik exploitations not that
you'd like you key bars in that region
but you'd be free of the normal baryonic
matter we're familiar with and be able
to take a rather direct look at a matter
of that type now such a machine is in
fact under construction in Brookhaven
those of you who remember the Isabel
project will perhaps recognize the
tunnel this is known as the relativistic
heavy ion collider it is a machine which
will be fed by the tandem and AGS
complex which I guess a few weeks ago
managed to accelerate the gold nuclei
that are needed for this project and
it's it's currently under construction
and expected to complete in about five
years from today as we stand there may
very well be a parallel effort go on at
CERN
it's not quite clear how that will
evolve though I think we'll hear later
today about discussions concerning the
Large Hadron Collider which would be
concerns version of a machine of SSC
type it's been pointed out it's learn
that since they are constructing
injectors for LED beams and have put
heavy ions through the SPS that you
could just as well carry those out to
the LHC so if that came to pass instead
of the hundreds upon hundreds of that
we'll have a trick which should form the
central region it might very well be
able to be possible to get out to center
of mass energies on the order of one pev
if you add it all up in more
conventional units that'd be about three
TeV per nucleon for lead ions I think I
can go on at some length about how one
goes about detecting a court glowing
plasma I think the only candid answer to
that is once we get through the
exploratory phase and this particular
branch of research we'll know it's there
has been a fairly large program started
to do that at Brookhaven and it's CERN
and I'm happy to notice from asking
yesterday - Steve Steadman for a list of
who is now in the heavy iron group that
they're back - some dozen students are
in fact involved in that program so a
few years down the road we hope to see
another good set of MIT graduates